-Good evening
and Happy Thanksgiving!
I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
and now, let's get to the news.
Happy Thanksgiving, everybody.
Let me just say
I hope your Thanksgiving
was just like mine --
taped ahead of time,
so you can watch football.
[ Laughter ]
Today was Thanksgiving, so,
if you're watching right now,
I'm guessing sex on a trundle
bed didn't work out?
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
the average cost
for a Thanksgiving meal
for 10 people this year is
around $64, plus,
whatever you owe your cousin
for hooking you up.
[ Laughter ]
The Supreme Court said this week
that the IRS can send
former President Trump's
tax return to Congress,
but, luckily, it's Thanksgiving,
so, he's got one more trick
up his sleeve.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
around half of Americans said
that they would rather
spend time with their family
on Thanksgiving
than receive $1,000 cash,
as opposed to my family,
who I had to pay to hang out
with me tonight.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Vogue released pictures this
week from President Biden's
granddaughter Naomi's
White House wedding,
including photos
with First Lady Dr. Jill Biden.
They would've published
President Biden's photo,
but they all featured
a big thumb in the corner.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ]
Uh, that's a good one!
[ Laughter ]
According to the latest numbers,
the price of ham
has increased this year
by more than 9%,
but, eventually, it's expected
to start spiraling.
[ Laughter and groans ]
Look, if things get tense
with your family this weekend,
just tell the spiraling joke.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
according to a new survey,
33% of Americans said that they
definitely would not participate
in a turkey trot race
over the Thanksgiving holiday,
unless, of course,
there's a line
for the downstairs bathroom.
"Make way!
Make way!"
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]